answer to congestion on valley roads
plans to expand the vegas loop are
moving forward yeah it shows stops
really all over the strip the project
could one day get you from the airport
to downtown las vegas in about 10
minutes underground sasha loftis is live
with what this means for properties
along the corridor
denise and brian this station here is
part of the vegas loop that is already
up and running across the convention
center now this expansion approved today
means this station here would just be a
piece of the puzzle as this entire
project takes a huge leap forward
people talk about the old days
but
today is better than ever been kenny
epstein knows las vegas
he's dedicated decades to our local
gaming industry and owns and operates
the el cortez
he and chief operating officer mike
nolan can't wait to see the vegas loop
right outside the iconic downtown
property this has been probably
one of the greatest things ever happened
to las vegas clark county commissioners
approved plans wednesday to expand the
underground tunnel 29 miles and offer 51
stops from the airport to the strip
downtown las vegas and even unlv this
project is going to be a game changer
for the city lvcva ceo steve hill says
the system which is built and funded by
elon musk's boring company is a great
way to cut down on traffic congestion
while boosting business it allows our
visitors our customers
to experience everything that we have
here and as for epstein and nolan
they're thrilled to have more exposure
in their side of the city again it's all
about convenience as we travel by
electric car
right into the future just make it
better better for everybody
now construction on the expansion should
start in the next six to 12 months the
expansion of the tunnel from here at the
convention center over to resorts world
we're told is already under construction
it's about halfway done and it should be
completely wrapped up that portion of
the tunnel by the first quarter of 2022
reporting live in las vegas tonight
sasha loftis a live local now